welcome to the David Pakman show I am
fairing cousin sitting in for David
Pakman today if you've been paying
attention to Donald Trump's Twitter feed
as I know most of us like to do from
time to time you kind of get the feeling
that this man never really knows exactly
what he wants to say about anything but
one thing we can always count on is the
fact that eventually every day or so
he's gonna start talking about the
alleged witch-hunt being launched by
robert muller and those 13 angry
democrats on the special prosecutors
team but what we really need to
understand here though is that donald
trump is repeating the exact same failed
strategy that richard nixon used to
avoid the watergate scandal in the
months leading up to the firing of
special prosecutor Archibald Cox back in
the Watergate investigation when all
that was at its peak the Nixon team
Nixon and his lawyers came up with a new
strategy they were tired of trying to
tell the public he had done nothing
wrong he'd done nothing wrong so what
they did was they switched and they
began to launch attacks against
Archibald Cox they called it a witch
hunt I'm sure we've all seen the images
of those old newspaper clippings that
say Nixon sees witch-hunt an
investigation and they called him a
partisan hack saying that this was
launched for political purposes they
know there's nothing there
but they're going to do it anyway this
was a losing strategy for Nixon nobody
in the public actually bought into this
but nonetheless they use this very
flimsy pretext as their justification to
eventually fire the special prosecutor
that's you know the Saturday night
massacre everybody for the last year
here in the United States has been
waiting to see if Donald Trump is going
to launch his own Saturday night
Massacre and fire Robert Muller shut
down the special prosecutor's office but
again we go back to Nixon because what
Nixon had to do then after he fired Cox
he had to appoint another special
prosecutor you see they couldn't just
exactly end the investigation they had
already been gathering evidence they
were already talking to people they had
pretty much built their case at that
point yet it wasn't quite finished so
they hire the new special prosecutor who
after seeing what happened to the last
one realized you know what I've got to
do this pretty quickly and that is
exactly what happened after the special
prosecutor finished got a couple of uh
you know pleas from some of the people
involved in Watergate they then went and
presented what has been described as a
mountain of evidence as the basis for
impeachment against Richard Nixon and as
we all know Richard Nixon never got to
the point of impeachment because he
resigned because he understood he didn't
have the votes to save himself from that
there's not too much different from what
Donald Trump is doing right now compared
to what Nixon did back then but right
now we're still at kind of the planning
phase if you recall a few months ago
Rudy Giuliani made it very clear that
their new legal strategy was going to be
to try to discredit Muller and his team
that way whenever evidence eventually
came out you know whether it was against
the Trump associate or against Trump
himself the hardcore truckers in this
country wouldn't believe that it was
real if they spent enough time just
crediting this guy telling everyone he's
a partisan hack even though he's a
registered Republican they could
absolutely be certain that the public
would never support any kind of removal
of Donald Trump from the Oval Office
again unfortunately doesn't appear to be
working right now polls show that at
least half of this country is all on
board with impeachment so Trump if he's
going to continue following in the
footsteps of Richard Nixon his next move
could be to fire Robert Muller and a lot
of people are very frightened by that
prospect you know if he fires Muller
we immediately try to impeach at that
point should Congress go ahead and use
the 25th amendment to get him out of
office before we could even impeach but
here's the thing Muller is a smart guy
he has been playing this very well since
day one of this investigation and recent
reports tell us that one of the smartest
decisions he has made since becoming the
special prosecutor here is that he's
actually farming out the prosecution's
themselves once he has enough evidence
and he secures an indictment from the
grand jury they send that particular
prosecution along with all the evidence
to a new office some of them have gone
to just other you know DEA offices type
areas others have gone back to the
Department of Justice to go ahead and
handle the prosecution but either way
Robert Muller once he has what he needs
hands it off to another office so that
regardless of what happens the mahler
that prosecution isn't going to go away
the evidence isn't going to go away so
yes would be awful if he fires Muller
but that is not going to be the end of
this investigation at this point it may
not even slow it down Trump knows what's
coming that's why his tweets over the
last couple of weeks here have gotten so
outrageous just even more so than what
we're used to that's why according to
him back in 2013 he's drumming up all
this threat of war against Iran you know
if you've seen his old tweets 2013 he
said Obama might do that to try to
change the public opinion about him and
then he turns around and does it you
know almost five years later to the date
there's a reason for that he's freaked
out right now he understands that he
doesn't really have much time left until
this investigation concludes he doesn't
know what to do
he doesn't know who has flipped on him
whether it's somebody that used to work
for him or somebody that currently works
for him because that's another piece of
the puzzle it's not just all these
former campaign aides and campaign
staffers that Muller has pulled into
this investigation to question
people who currently work for the
president in the White House every
single day have been called before that
grand jury and Trump doesn't know what
they've said he doesn't know what the
other people have said who don't work
for him anymore he doesn't know what
kind of information to people like gates
and Flynn and Manta fort have handed
over he knows that
five witnesses in the mana fort trial
have been given immunity maybe they
turned something else over there's so
many unknowns right now for this guy
that he is absolutely losing his mind
and because he likes to do so very
publicly on Twitter we all get to see it
happen in real time let's just hope that
whatever the outcome is of this
investigation whether it's impeachment
whether it's you know acquittal whatever
it is let's hope that we get to that
conclusion before Donald Trump does
something drastic like I don't know
maybe starting a new war in the Middle
East that's not out of the realm of
possibility and considering his threat
from Monday it's something we all need
to take very seriously